في كوريا الجنوبية ، اشتهرت باسم bailina ، وهي
نجمة على YouTube ، وهي جزء من جيل من
مدوني ألعاب الجمال ، حيث ظهرت
المتابعين الذين يعرضون على النساء الأخريات
نصائحهن وحيلهن ، وهذا مجرد جزء من
روتين المكياج الخاص بنا الذي كانت تحولك إليه في
كل مرة تغادر فيها المنزل ولكن
اسمها الحقيقي هو Bayon Jeong وقد
جذب إظهار وجهها الخالي من المكياج الانتباه أكثر من
أي مقاطع فيديو نشرتها قبل العنوان ،
فأنا لست جميلة
، لقد كشفت نفسها عن
آلامها الشخصية وشاركت فقط
بعض الرسائل المليئة بالكراهية.
تلقي الفيديو الفيروسي بانتظام
جعل وجهها واحدًا من أكثر الوجهات وضوحًا في
حملة متنامية تسمى الهروب من
مشد القاع ، وأنا لا أطبخ
مشروعًا على وجه الخصوص ، لذا نعم
حركة شهدت نساء في كوريا الجنوبية يحطمن
مكياجهن وينشرن الدليل
تستهدف صور مثل هذه
صناعة التجميل في كوريا الجنوبية ،
الضغط لتبدو مثالية ، مما يجعل
أنظمة المكياج المتقنة هي الموضة ولكن
الهروب من الكورسيه هو أكثر من مجرد عمق الجلد
أيضًا.  ازدهار جنسيًا - غنت
لعنة أغنية تخنقه ، أعني أنني أفترض أن
هؤلاء النساء جزء من
نادي نسوي.  الجامعة مثل
الآخرين الذين هربوا من مشدهم قاموا
بقطع شعرهم من أجل
الاهتمام الممنوح لبعض الكعك في قارة
معلقة مع كونها المخروطي المضاد للبيستو
، وحتى John Keegan ESO كان طاقم شرنقة
قرص واحد IO kanetsugu Koyukuk Azaria
وعن Quintana me Joey
أنا لست موهومًا صغيرًا ، فهذه الحركة
تنبع من ذوبان رد الفعل النسوي
ضد التحرش والاعتداء
[الموسيقى]
يقول نشطاء إن الهروب من المخصر الآن
يتعلق بإدخال النسوية في
الحياة اليومية للمرأة من خلال معرفة شخص ما
اعتقدت كولكابا أنه يجب أن أعاقب
تقول باي إنها اكتسبت
الوقت والمال من ترك روتين المكياج الخاص بها ،
فهي تنفقه على تعلم
لغات جديدة تدرس النساء  inism
والسعي إلى مستقبل في التمثيل في الوقت الحالي ، تخزن
نفسها بنفسها الكسندرا مجال CNN